[Music]
seven surprising facts about NASA in
2012 NASA released a recording of
Earth's song which sounds like this what
you're hearing are radio waves detected
by a NASA spacecraft as it flew through
Earth's radiation belts due to
government regulations NASA could not
provide its Apollo astronauts with life
insurance but Life magazine paid a
$100,000 policy for each Apollo
astronaut that flew in return for rights
to the personal stories
this policy lasted up through Apollo 11
Neil Armstrong submitted his astronaut
application two weeks late some sources
suggest a friend of Neal's slipped his
application into the pile for
consideration the NASA could not confirm
this the inventor of the Super Soaker
Lonnie Johnson was a NASA scientist who
helped develop the US Air Force's
stealth bomber NASA assembles its giant
rockets in the Vehicle Assembly Building
which is so massive that it has its own
weather NASA employees have reported
that rain clouds have formed below the
ceiling on very humid days to keep
moisture under control the building has
10,000 tons of air conditioning
equipment including 125 ventilators on
the roof
the only piece of art on the moon called
the fallen astronaut memorial sculpture
was secretly put there by Apollo 15 in
1971 the sculpture commemorates all
astronauts and cosmonauts who died to
advance space exploration though the
item was tested and cleared for flight
the upper ranks of NASA management
didn't know about the sculpture until
after it was already in space throughout
the 60s NASA astronauts were treated to
a pair of new cars each year the idea
came from Jim Rothman who owned a
Chevrolet Cadillac dealership in Florida
and had befriended a few astronauts
including Alan Shepard most of the
astronauts reportedly chose a family car
for their wives and a Corvette for
themselves